from 2010 to 2019 technology changed in
major ways which had a huge impact on
the movies we watched from realistic
environments to convincing fake animals
to aging and D aging actors and even
doubling them it almost felt like there
was nothing CGI couldn't do let's take a
look at some CGI from the past decade
that took movies to the next level who
would have thought that a biopic about
Facebook co-founder Mark Zuckerberg
could also be a CGI Marvel Armie Hammer
played twins Cameron and Tyler
Winklevoss I'm 65 to 20 and there's two
of me actors playing double is nothing
new typically when an actor plays two
characters that interact filmmakers use
techniques like split screens and
over-the-shoulder shots which this movie
certainly used just look at this shot
where the twins are walking together but
we don't see either of their heads
that's because the movie used two
different actors actor Josh pence served
as army hammers body double hammers face
was then grafted on the Pence's body in
post-production
the two would switch off who would be
Cameron and who would be Tyler from
seeing the scene face replacement didn't
start with the social network but this
movie was at the time the first truly
convincing version of this technology
especially since it was a movie with no
sci-fi elements
Armie Hammer wasn't the celebrity he is
today and for a while people actually
thought he was two different people
these techniques paved the way for an
entire movie about doubles in the form
of us and for Chris Evans to fight
himself in Avengers endgame
[Music]
this feat also involved face replacement
from Lola visual-effects which took what
it learned on the social network and
applied it to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
prior to his transformation into Captain
America Steve Rogers is small and
scrawny nothing like actor Chris Evans
for some shots actor leander Dini
doubled as the skinny Steve Rogers for
others the VFX team replaced Dinis
entire head with Evans head Evans would
shoot the scene looking like himself
Dini would watch Evans perform the scene
and precisely mimic his every move the
crew would shoot a clean plate with no
character at all then VFX artists would
place Evans face over D knees but for
most of these scenes the VFX team
digitally Shrunk Evans down for this
Lola visual effects invented a new
method for shrinking which had called
Steve slimming Lowell a visual effects
artists that they learned a lot from
this experience like how to highlight an
actor's performance without letting CGI
get in the way that's a lesson they
applied when de-aging Samuel Jackson and
Captain Marvel
[Music]
Chris Evans wasn't the only Marvel hero
who went through a CGI transformation
Captain America Civil War feature daddy
aged Robert Downey jr. as young Tony
Stark
Lola visual effects once again stepped
in here some cases of d aging involve a
body double and others involve replacing
the actor with a digital double however
new technology allowed Downey to perform
the scene normally as himself VFX
artists use digital compositing to D age
the actor this way Downey could still
perform the scene as usual and the VFX
team wouldn't lose the actors many
nuances which is a technological
achievement that helped three years
later in the Irish Man which we'll get
to in a bit d aging has become an
essential process changes can be as big
as lifting skin and acetyls increasing
light reflecting off skin one of the
biggest challenges of D aging a
well-known star is that audiences are
familiar with how they looked when they
were younger especially with an actor
like Downey who has been in movies since
he was a child
so the VFX team analyzed old footage of
him in 1987's less than zero which helps
explain why this young version of Tony
Stark was so convincing D aging was not
invented in this decade an early use
came in 2006 his x-men The Last Stand
looking at the results from that decade
to this one you can see just how much
better it's gotten
[Music]
technology can both be age and age an
actor Hayley Atwell was aged up for a
pivotal scene where she plays a much
older Peggy Carter once again thank Lola
visual effects for this transformation
every movie is just an excuse for visual
effects artists to build on the visual
effects work done before and get better
in an interview
Lola VFX artists said they believed they
spent so much time perfecting carter's
neck that they didn't spend nearly
enough time on her face
five years later Captain America would
finally get to act his age in Avengers
endgame as Chris Evans was aged up using
a mix of CGI makeup and a body double
but this time Evans were neck
prosthetics so the VFX artists could
spend even more time perfecting his
older face
thanks to motion capture technology
actors could show their full range of
emotions while being transformed into
basically any kind of creature mocap was
honed in the 2000s in the Lord of the
Rings trilogy King Kong and avatar it
became commonplace in the 2010s hitting
its stride over the course of the Planet
of the Apes reboot trilogy much of the
work on all these movies was done by the
famed visual effects to do what a
digital by the time of Rise of the
Planet of the Apes cameras were able to
capture the most subtle of movements and
details which made the Apes more
believable and Rhys was also the first
movie to ever shoot motion capture in a
live-action location as opposed to just
a bare soundstage this development would
later help them to shoot in even more
challenging locations like the Vancouver
rainforest in town of the Planet of the
Apes and on beaches and in deep snow in
war for the Planet of the Apes
it wasn't Andy Serkis his only big
motion capture character of the 2010s
Serkis played the menacing supreme
leader snoke he showed up as a hologram
in the force awakens and then in person
in the last Jedi
according to Industrial Light and Magic
creative director Ben Morris they didn't
even have the tools to make Snoke look
this realistic in the force awakens by
the time the last Jedi rolled around
they were able to add so many details to
the skin like age spots and veins the
visual effects team shot circus with
high-resolution cameras positioned at
every conceivable angle to create a
digital clone of him as circus performed
they could automatically capture every
subtle facial move from how he smiles to
how he furrows his brow they even
studied the elderly to see how light
would realistically hit Snoke skin the
technology ILM developed in
collaboration with Disney research has
been used to capture many actors one of
the most prominent Josh Brolin
asthenosphere of the Avengers villains
skin
in the live-action Jungle Book remake
actor Neel Sethi played Mowgli and was
the only human character in the film he
acted on a completely empty soundstage
besides these puppets and creature
performers that would then be digitally
replaced with the actual cgi characters
the biggest breakthrough on this movie
muscle movement MPC film developed a new
software for animating an animal's
muscle structure all of MPC films work
directly contributed to its work on 2019
s The Lion King a VFX artist perfected
their already developed muscle and
movement simulations they also added
more joints and bones under the skin as
a way to make the characters movements
more natural otherwise CGI creations run
the risk of being either too bouncy or
too stiff when they move and the
environments created for the Jungle Book
were made in virtual production which
required virtual reality techniques
allowing filmmakers to step foot in
these environments and better place
their characters in them this was also
used to a more advanced degree in 2019
The Lion King but with great CGI comes
great responsibility
[Music]
this Star Wars prequel brought back the
Empire sinister grand moff tarkin
however actor Peter Cushing died in 1994
so Industrial Light and Magic use CGI to
bring him back to life another actor guy
Henry stood in his Cushing and did his
best target impression a mounted camera
rig captured his facial movements then
ILM used his performance as a guide to
digitally recreate Cushing the whole
process took about 18 months to complete
while Cushing's estate gave its blessing
the decision was still controversial
should you bring back an actor from the
dead this issue isn't going anywhere
the upcoming Vietnam War era drama
finding Jack caused an uproar with news
that it cast a CGI version of long
deceased Hollywood legend James Dean
[Music]
in Blade Runner 2049 the VFX wizards at
MPC film created a digital double of
actress Shaun young so she could reprise
her role as Rachel from the original
Blade Runner it may be the most
convincing digital double yet to create
the digital Rachel a 3d scanned young
and aged her back to how she looked in
the original Blade Runner like with
muscles and joints in the jungle book
the most crucial CGI here is what you
don't see the skull to create a CGI
skull they combine the 3d scan with a
life cast done of young shortly after
the original Blade Runner focusing on
building this character's skull allowed
the artist to build the characters
de-aged features around it in addition
they focused on subtleties and Young's
face and even how makeup was done in the
1980s actress Loren Peeta doubled onset
before being replaced by the D aged
young VFX Supervisor John Nelson also
said the team closely studied the
characters emotions in the original
Blade Runner and incorporated them into
the double helping to make real and fake
almost indistinguishable digital doubles
got so realistic that they would
eventually allow Will Smith to act
alongside a younger version of himself
while performing both parts in 2019
Gemini man but creating digital doubles
won't cause actors to lose their jobs
[Music]
in Martin Scorsese's mobster epic Robert
DeNiro Al Pacino and Joe Pesci were
de-aged to play Frank Sheeran Jimmy
Hoffa and Russell Bufalino during
various times in their lives there was
no need for the actors to wear helmets
tennis balls or dots on their faces the
tracking marks were invisible scenes had
to be captured with three cameras at
once there was one central camera the
two additional witness cameras were
infrared which removed all the shadows
from a given shot a new software called
flux revealed a lot more details in the
actors faces like how their faces are
shaded and the way the lighting hits
them for additional reference the VFX
team studied the cast filmography this
allowed the actors to focus on their
performances and the visual effects
artists to focus on the D aging but
there's something CG I still can't do
like making actors movements look
younger so a posture coach came to the
set to make sure the actors were moving
appropriate to the ages forgiven seen
perhaps the aging and actor's movements
is a CGI breakthrough for the 2020s
you